[Musik]
hallo und herzlich willkommen zur fans
fällt heute mache ich einmal versuchen
mit erdbeeren 125 g butter 100 gramm
zucker eine prise salz 1 teelöffel seine
extrakt 3 160 gramm mehl 2 teelöffel
backpulver 40 gramm kakao und schon hat
25 km
ich mag hat den maulwurf kuchen weil die
allein kindergarten ist und meine mama s
cup treffen und erwarten hetzer würden
wir die butter mit dem zucker salz
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dauert die ewigkeit
so hätten sie aber den hocker benutzen
weil die schüssel suchen also das geht
am besten wenn ihr ein handrührgerät
nimmt oder kitchenaid jetzt werde ich
die butter mit dem zucker und der prise
salz cremig also die mutter
[Musik]
wir brauchen die seite 387
naja
[Musik]
so lange zeit vergessen
hätte ich mir vielleicht mal vorher
jetzt 14
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich drei bis vier minuten um
die welt wie sie mache ich einen nach
dem anderen rein
letzten geschichte das backpulver mit
dem mehl
jetzt muss ich das meer langsam mit der
milch hineingehen und dem backpulver
[Musik]
helmut klein
ich glaube ich brauche man ein muster
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und gerade eben habe ich auch den ring
also den bakken das papier eingeschlagen
also ich hab grad irgendwann backing
angeschlagen
und jetzt kommt da datei kann
[Musik]
später dran streichen
am rand verteidigt und ein bisschen
programmen
[Musik]
so jetzt mache ich mein umfeld also rund
160 grad ober unterhitze
[Musik]
ich habe es mir gemacht
braucht ihr film von akram sahne 200
gramm saure sahne 30 gramm puderzucker
etwas anna park zum steif schlagen er
etwas meine letzte 100 gramm
getrockneter den schneebesen also den
aufsatz für die saarner da in die sana
ag sich jetzt die saure sahne ran
dann gehe ich noch im poker mit zu tun
[Musik]
und das bisschen weg sagt ihr könnt auch
dafür tankwaggon haben
also wahr nehmen wir kenne ich ja besser
aber da war schnittlauch wirklich jetzt
rum
so
von polen
pro 100 gramm gebe ich jetzt einen
löffel japan
es war halb
so habe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein traum
[Musik]
jetzt muss hier hat man von der saane
kostprobe 351 sekunden
er sieht richtig gut aus
so ähnlich nach draußen und blätter
himbeeren und wir sind ein bisschen
weiter dann muss den sind die so klein
[Musik]
lieberman dann kann man ja schon
eigentlich glaubt da hinten ja stimmt
[Musik]
ich muss gucken wie lange ich habe jetzt
die sonne kurz im kühlschrank gemacht 45
minuten ungefähr und jetzt durch die
hälfte von dem schoko drops l4
unterliegen also ist auch nicht alles
rein machen sondern halt noch ein
bisschen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt die sahne und die schoko
trockenreiben gemacht und jetzt stelle
ich sie in den schrank ist der kuchen
abgesetzt
ein kuchen ist offen
abrufen gekommen und ist abgekühlt und
jetzt stelle ich die eltern dass sie
später auch im kuchen stehen können er
schneidet ein weil ich ein bisschen vom
kuchen ab und
also wir jetzt nicht zu klein sein muss
sagen zum beispiel liegt die leiche
weil samstag ist hier ganz viele davon
finden und klicken wir dann als der
gruppe nutzen
[Musik]
ich hab gerade eben den kuchen und
kuchen das jetzt abgekühlt und jetzt ist
abgekühlt und jetzt will er sich
irgendwann der form
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt tue ich meinen kuchen und torten
red dot auf massig der mittelwert von
raum und geschafft ich habe schon ist
geschafft also ich habe jetzt ein
kleines kind mit dem bestechen zu nehmen
zu den kleinen kreis rhein
ich warte ich brauche dafür ein messer
und jetzt fröhlich das mit der hand aus
ihr ganz natürlich auch mit einem löffel
boston hatte brauche eine schale alles
ich habe alles aus mir rausgeholt
[Musik]
friedlich fluffig empfangen
umdrehen ist ein bisschen warm ein ganz
ganz menge bisschen
[Musik]
jetzt wirklich nacheinander hat die etwa
die hälfte von dem schock und drops die
ich noch immer hatte
und wenn man dann rein weist das ist so
krank wird also mache ich halt noch
schaffe jobs drüber über dr
[Musik]
jetzt mache ich die creme drauf jeder
hofft aber mein lieblingsteil
zauberschlag ich verweist halt so
jetzt tue ich hier die creme drauf am
anfang sieht es ein bisschen viel aus
aber dann gibt's keinen schönen motto
flügel sind nicht sehr viel sagen
mit streiche ich es bei meiner mama
[Musik]
die streicht ist jetzt ein bisschen
unter dass es halt im schönen maulwurf
flügel gibt es nicht schlimm wenn man
hier zum beispiel bisschen die ab
landshut
weil da kommen ja noch die kekse mit auf
ich muss jetzt den restlichen teig hier
gehen wir raus gemacht haben bisschen
zerbröseln dass ich ihnen gleich und
klatschen kann und tricks vorsichtig
wir suchen ja immer schale muss prüfe
ich sein weil sonst gibts halt dicke
brocken und den kann man sich gut an
schneiden und geht halt auch nicht gut
aus
[Musik]
natürlich gleich gestopft
der stoff wird
ich frag mich noch im weg bringen
kannawurf schmeckt richtig lecker mit
bert dann habe ich dann die propheten
es ist auch noch nichts wissen dieser
kuchen und aufgestellt richtig merken es
hat mein lieblings kuchen können sie mal
auf der unteren stufen rein
[Musik]
ich mache die co
ich mache gerade die alle leuchtet ja
auch
kommt mal wieder rauskommen
[Musik]
dass unser gast auch kommt er daher
stark geschnitten ich muss echt sagen
und samira hat der kuchen sieht
fabelhaft aus
ich hab's nicht technischen macht nix
mehr
ich weiß auch warum weil du das messer
so hält auch wenn das vielleicht so
genau
effektvoll der schöne maulwurf kuchen
julia hast du schon im august oben
gemacht drees mir ganz weit voraus so
lag der anstieg beim ersten stücke sind
natürlich schwierig so schön gemacht
echt toll sieht sich sehen
die schippe drauf hast du dir noch
draufgelegt
die langsamste voll lecker ja du hast
ein eigenes baby und ab dann über dem zu
den kanal sozusagen ab morgen und wir
machen drei tage frei
so machen wir das also viel spaß
weiterhin auch so ich moderiere nicht so
wäre es seine moderation
du darfst aber ruhig meine app benutzen
also wir können deine rezept doch in
meiner app laden okay wenn ihr noch
keine eigene programmieren willst ok
also wenn du möchtest kannst du deine
erwarben okay da würde ich mich freuen
wie schon gastbeitrag die frösche gibt
es en bloc sondern machen die so
gastbeiträgen ist mir reicht bin echt
stolz auf dich durch richtig ein ganz
ganz tolles maulwurf kuchen gemacht mit
erdball offenbar gab es für die kleinen
da oben
ok vielen dank dass wir probieren doch
vielleicht schneiden wir uns noch ein
stückchen ab und dann nachmachen
es hat spaß gemacht ich bin auch etwas
getroffen und ich auch dass ich direkt
dabei sein durfte einmal zu besuchen ein
kindergarten geben sich wieder zu klein
bleibst du jetzt für immer
nein ich hoffe ihr habt auch so tolle
kinder die torte backen kann welchen
kuchen halten also kein papa auch
mitessen
voll gut richtig lecker
[Musik]